hello and welcome to this video playing
crocodiles small hmm crocodile big would
be more more a threat probably what
about the open society I could do the
open but I mean I'd like to also
practice my main Bishop b5 repertoire so
let's do it
I'm really quite happy that after having
worked on that efore keep it simple
repertoire then I'm now able to play one
year for on a regular basis at least
sometimes it's not my main opening but I
don't really mind doing it once in a
while in particular if I fear the
opposition fits let's say with Maya for
apat one even know what to expect or if
I don't really fear the opponent's
preparation all that much I'd like to go
a four or sometimes they play a
particular line that I feel ok I'd like
to have this with white and I go e
faults and classical time controller
chess Knight to e5 ok yeah that usually
signals the intention to try some a6 b5
it's difficult to get through though I'm
on that a lot on that square
[Music]
okay not entirely certain what this is
doing
I'm be tempted to go age three and then
a form that is a bit provocative him to
play age five King age seven like some
sequins like f4 knight c6 Knight f3 and
then possibly Knight g5 f5 could be
dangerous I mean he has weakened his
King position quite a bit down okay
so huh wait um Queen to c7
I also have just 95 as a good solution
but it feels lame truly feels lame in
comparison okay so now on I to to a-1
tonight on g5 mmm not not totally clear
actually f5 immediately comes to mind as
well he's got night c5 though against so
let's let's do this the night on g5
looks looks like an annoying piece of
[Music]
course one attraction of the Bishop b5
check line for me is that I have played
the maracas see bind my whole chest life
with white from one c4 193 and you get
my Roxy by in style position say all the
time and I have an excellent score with
those and always feel happy if I get my
roxy wine on the board always feel like
okay now now i need to do some stupid
stuff to lose he i'm actually
threatening to take on g6 like a g6 okay
is he preventing what I'm saying that
I'm threatened
it's 95 I thought 95 takes 97 shake I
can take g6 here I don't know if I
wanted to do that right away a 6 is
quite a week but
it's not clear that it Nets me all that
much
okay I'm going to take but it takes with
this one okay
yeah 95 is always part of this but it
doesn't doesn't really do all that much
yeah maybe this is an idea a 95 next
putting some additional pressure here on
f7 rook f5 would have been interesting
actually
only now registers anyway again it's not
a big problem now a queen j f5 is now
also part of this position Queen to f5
why do I have anything better I mean if
I immediately take and play Queen to f5
he will have to take other twins that
almost wins he can take with the pawn
though oops
okay Queen a5 after look at the clock a
little bit
only have 18 seconds which is a bit
excessive I should have played this a
lot quicker they weren't any super
sophisticated decisions to make so
absolutely reason to spend that much
time
okay
they cannot take with the bishop not
quite sure why but you cannot do it I
mean okay I can take a plane ith seven
and take them okay yeah I mean Knights
is not having a lot of squares it's
maybe an issue
it's not like it's easy to play for him
yeah just just what step at a time okay
yeah I think it's probably just winning
at the end but you don't need to move on
time of course yeah it was a very normal
ish looking position b3
yeah and now the next couple of moves
I'm not quite sure about really I mean
it's not so easy to handle this kind of
position with black because you are
really not very active and one thing you
have to keep in mind that when black
starts with those two moves the most
likely lines he's aiming for is the
night off or the dragon and they are
both fairly dynamic and tactical I mean
rowdy is understand under statement a
bit here sometimes they are super
tactical and then he's suddenly in this
and I mean there's no tactics know that
no dynamic possibilities for black
you're basically sitting in a position
that is arguably still very slightly
worse and sometimes what happens is that
black players
yeah rather aimlessly sometimes
aimlessly I know it's a bit harsh but
they maneuver back and forth but they
don't really get anywhere near in black
should try 6565 those are the classic
palm breaks yes those breaks
I can try to trade pieces and this is
not such a bad strategy if you just
simply try to try to trade stuff him
however I don't really see a very clean
path to equality
after looking at this quite a bit I
think white is always a little bit more
comfortable it's not a lot but it is it
is there yeah again 95i not quite sure
where is where this aims you know what
what the goal is
rooks e1 and now h5 yeah again I don't
don't quite see the point it weakens and
it has no big upside sometimes there is
the idea King h7 Queen here Queen h8 but
that looks very
slow here very slow ok Queen d2 is kind
of normal King age seven and now age
three simply trying to play f4 without
Knight g4 happening Queen c7 and a form
and 92 d7 year and now I think f5 is
also possible right yeah it's also given
by the comp I wasn't sure it looks like
a good move you always have to keep in
mind that you give away some score some
control but you will weaken lucky em but
you weaken the back black position a lot
like you this for example this looks
rather awkward so what the engine gives
see it wants a bit mysterious to me but
now +2 seems high
I mean I mean I I'm of course white is
bad of it +2 is is a lot maybe it's this
maybe it really is mounting quickly
Bishop before 95 stuff you guys that's
what the engine gives ya okay I mean
don't think 93 is a mistake or anything
I was maybe delaying f5 unnecessarily 95
and one one typical idea here is that 95
is on for white if I go here here it's
important to note that after King evade
this is a text so I'm losing a piece
after f5 I actually have the idea of 95
again if he plays something completely
irrelevant which is yeah okay let's just
show then I can actually do this because
now I can take then he cannot really can
go here and give me another pawn with
check
now the knight has an escape square
basically by taking on g6
was check there is one idea of f5 but
okay he does not play a non move of
course he plays 95 which covers those
squares and points take I would have
expected F checks but okay it probably
doesn't really matter all that much look
at five I missed that that is a that
looks very logical get the F look on the
air foul doubled queen f2 is not
terrible but that it was a good a good
option maybe better option
Queen f5 should be a good month 98 and
yeah queen h7 is a lot stronger I came
here
may I looked at this but I didn't really
didn't really register that Bishop h6
and this is fantastic for wide am okay
okay this this is not bad but it's not
as good yeah black yeah basically let
the clock run out I mean it's it's not
really a position where you where moves
come easy easy to him okay guys thanks
for watching